Exploration-based learning is very common in the real world. You and
I do it all the time. You need to prop open a door, you bring a chair, and
you use it to prop open the door because it just put an explanation for
why the chair, in fact, can prop open a door. There is a sheaf of papers on
a desk with the shuffling around. You take a coffee mug, put it on the sheaf of
paper that acts as a paperweight. Another example or explanation best learned.
You and I are constantly dealing with novel situations,
we are constantly coming up with creative solutions to them. How do we do it?
One way is if we use existing concepts but use them in new ways.
We find new connections between them by building explanations for them. This is
sometimes called Speed Up learning because we're not learning new concepts,
we're simply connecting existing concepts. But it's a very powerful way of
dealing with a large number of situations. And today in class, we'll learn
how we can build AI agents that can do the same thing that you and I do so well.